hello good people of YouTube my name is
Dave Rubin I am the newest host here at
the Young Turks Network this is the
Rubin report my name is Reuben
it worked it was nice it was me a Ruben
Studdard he works cheaper yet they still
went with me pretty good we've got a
great show for you what we're gonna be
doing here on the Rubin report is hot
topics things that you know about things
that maybe you don't know about with the
group of people that again maybe you
know maybe you don't know but I know
that you should know them think about
that we got a great group three fine
people with us today
Marcellus how are you doing my man Marky
Mark on Twitter I'm very good
welcome get no complaints you got no
complaints and everyone knows that I am
a very very bitter person who complains
about everything but I lead a blessed
life all right
bitter but no complaints good start
maggot not yet
Jackie Monahan comedian and funny lady a
raconteur I would call thank you why are
you doing dad I'm excellent you know
life is treating me very good as well
four blasts and miracles that's two I
don't know and getting there it's Dave
Holmes a man who has one of my favorite
Twitter BIOS the guy from this thing
that thing no the other things someone
just the guy from the thing in general
you know I mean the guy from the thing
you saw it may be yeah it may be but
maybe not also who knows who knows
you've been are to be here well I am
graduates on the new show thank you guys
for coming in I'm thrilled to be doing
this with you guys and what we're gonna
be doing as I said it's hot topics we're
gonna be chopping them up distributing
them throughout the week and we're gonna
start with what was the big story last
week of course involving a glass of
water
and a man with a very dry mouth of
course I'm talking about Marco Rubio
giving the rebuttal to Obama's State of
the Union address let's take a look
nothing has frustrated me more than
false choices like the one that
president laid out tonight the choice
isn't just between big government or big
business what we need is an accountable
efficient and effective government that
allows small new businesses to create
more middle-class jobs alright so that
was the swig of water heard round the
world
guys everyone's all over this on Twitter
social media everywhere what's your take
Marcellus you first really good product
placement for Poland Springs
unfortunately they should have maybe
gone with one of the little girls you
know Sasha Malia the Obama girls oh that
they should have just been standing
there no they should have put the bottle
in their hands because I mean at the end
of the day who cares about like some
white that was like you yeah they're
they're better spokesmodels all around
absolutely yeah so this was a does Marco
Rubio not fit with Poland Springs is
that where the product placement issue
is I think Poland Spring doesn't want to
be associated with panic because that -
that that is the content of every panic
attack I've ever had I always I'm afraid
that I'm just gonna you know I'm gonna
have a dry mouth and I'm just gonna like
break down on live television that dude
did it in front of one of the biggest
audiences in the world Jackie you're a
well seasoned performer nothing ever
breaks you what what do you make of a
dry mouth politician that's why I'm on
stage keeping yourself liquid I just
Chomp Chomp boy yeah he looks crazy
doesn't he looks insane that's like I
couldn't take my eyes off that because
he's not taking his eyes off the camera
yeah it was kind of like what porn yes
how much you miss do you think was that
was that kind of stiffness that he has
to keep looking at the camera the whole
time yet we're all watching him going
man you need a drink like how much do
you think just the awkwardness of having
to talk to the camera itself the whole
time played into this I can't believe
there isn't like a pill that he could
have taken or spray that would have
stopped that dry mouth in the moment
remember quench go
how very glands going burst in your
mouth yes right in your mouth and we so
like things that burst in our mouths
yeah one of the things that I thought
was interesting in the fallout from this
thing Watergate as they were calling it
was that CNN actually I didn't make that
one up unfortunately CNN actually put a
car on that said career-ender what
question mark could this be a career
ender and is that like the point that
we're at at this point where you just
you can't great you know you get a
little parched
and next thing you know your career this
is the young star of the Republicans I
mean I guess you know we could talk to
Howard Dean about that who was you know
who was the presumptive nominee of the
Democratic Party a few years ago and
then he made a weird noise with his
mouth yeah and I was a joke you know
it's remember that absolute now I think
things are a little bit accelerated I
think it's you know we go through memes
very quickly he was quick to make fun of
it and I think I think that is just that
was just real that was my marketing
oesophagus at work but but it's it's we
go through them so fast and I think
people jump on him so quickly that his
supporters are sort of gonna have his
back you know what I mean and say like
well it's not fair for CNN it's called a
career ender he's probably the only
Republican under a hundred he's sort of
good-looking this is like their big hope
if Watergate is his undoing who else are
they gonna like shoved down our throats
who else is there there's nobody there's
no one else
Jackie laughs not Britney Spears can
come back from flashing her vagina I
like this guy I'll be okay you know the
bummer about it is that you know it
distracted from the content of the
speech which was sort of hateful and not
a whole lot of her new ideas yeah I
thought it was the ultimate distraction
because the speech had absolutely no
content anyway so it's like oh let me
water yeah
he really thought no one was gonna
notice the guy seemed like he was like
they're gonna notice that yeah and that
is the funny stiff part of politics that
we all see all the time like he kept
looking at the camera and yet leaning in
in such a way like no one's gonna see
what I'm about to do